[موسيقى]
حلو الواحد يساعد اللي حوله سواء من اهله
او اح صح كلام وداعم العائله ومحبتهم مهمه
في حياه كل شخص وتتكلم عن تجربتها هيف
العوا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته انا اسمي
هيف العواد عمري 13 سنه انا اليوم راح
اتكلم لكم عن الاطفال الاطفال شيء جدا
جميل في الحياه واكيد ان كلنا نحبهم لكن
انا اليوم راح اسلط الضوء على اطفال
معينين حننا الا وهم اطفال متلازمه داون
والذي
لقبهم والذي لقبهم الاستاذ فهد الشنيفي
بهدايا الرحمن وهم فعلا هديه من الرحمن
تخيلوا مثلا ان اليوم انه ل 800 طفل في
العالم ينولد بس طفل واحد من ذوي متلازمه
داون متلازمه داون هو خلل في كروموسوم 21
كيف يعني خلل في كروموسوم 21 يعني ان
الانسان الطبيعي عنده 46 كروموسوم اما
متلازمه داون عنده 47 كروموسوم والخلل في
ذلك هو كروموسوم 21 واطلقوا عليه كروموسوم
السعاده الحين انا ابغاكم كلكم تشوفون
يدكم اليسار تلاحظون ان هنا في رقم 81 اما
متلازمه داون في الغالب تكون يدهم صافيه
محيه من الخطوط بس هنا في رقم 11 من فيكم
يعرف ليش سمها بمتلازمه داون نسبه الى
العالم البريطاني جون داون تدرون ليش انا
اليوم اخترت لكم موضوعي عن متلازمه داون
عشان اخوي البطل والجميل فيصل
[تصفيق]
عواد فصولي من ذوي متلازمه داون اول اول
ما طلع فصولي على الدنيا كانت صدمه جدا
حزينه لنا بس الحمد لله احنا مع مرور
الوقت بدلنا هذه الصدمه الحزينه الى
مفاجاه جدا جميله
[تصفيق]
وفصولي يوم كمل ست اشهر احنا دخلنا علاج
طبيعي لان متلازمه داون عندهم ارتخاء في
العضلات وايضا عندهم خلل فاذا احنا مره ما
اجتهدنا عليهم بسرعه ودخلهم علاج طبيعي
ممكن يصير عندهم ارتخاء او خلل في
العضلات والحمد
لله والحمد لله يوم كمل سنتين دخلناه في
مدرسه خاصه لذوي لازمه داون والحين فصولي
اخوي صار يعرف الالوان صار يعرف الارقام
فصولي اخوي مبدع فصي اخوي متميز فص يا
اخوي
[موسيقى]
بطل ويوم كمل خمس سنوات دخلنا في نادي
السباحه وانا بعد كنت ل اروح معه الاحظ ان
في اطفال طبيعيين يكملون سنتين او ثلاث
سنوات ولسه ما يعرفون يسبحون والحمد لله
انفص البطل خلال سنه واحده صار يعرف يسبح
[تصفيق]
متلازمه داون عندهم مواهب وابداعات بس
احنا لازم ننمي هذه الموهبه عشان يطلع لهم
مستقبل جميل باذن
الله الحمد لله هذه السنه الثانيه الفصولي
في دار تحفيظ قران كريم والحين هو حافظ
بعض الصور بس الصوره اللي ما راح احفظها
صوره الناس وان شاء الله ان بنستمر معه في
الدار لمن يختم القران كريم باذن
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الله بقول لكم شيء تدرون انا احيانا
اتضايق لما نروح اقاربنا او لما نروح
السوق تدرون ليش لان احيانا يجون يناظرون
في الصلي بنظره سيئه ليش ناظرهم بنظره
سيئه عادي هم اطفال طبيعيين يفهمون
ويستوعبون او انه يجون يقولون الله يشفيه
ليه احنا نقول الله يشفيه هذا مو مرض عشان
اهي تعالج هذه حاله وليست
مرض
[تصفيق]
وايضا متلازمه دا ما يصلح ان نعزل عن
المجتمع بالعكس لازم احنا نطلعهم للمجتمع
وهم اطفال جدا مبدعين وان شاء الله انه
بيصيرون من الابطال الجمي باذن
[تصفيق]
الله تبون تشوفون فصولي اخوي اللي يبغى
يشوف فصولي يرفع
يده
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اكيد
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
مفتوح
وهذا فصول يا اخوي اللي حكيت لكم قصته قول
لهم ايش
اسمك قوللهم احبكم
احبك وهذا كتاب فصولي اخوي في قصته وكيف
ان احنا نتعامل معه نفس الكلام اللي تو
قلته بس الكلام اللي قلته مبسط واسمه
طفوله من نوع اخر وان شاء الله ان بيعرض
قريبا في جميع
المكتبات
وفي النهايه لنكن يدا بيد لمساعده اطفال
وملاكه متلازمه دام شكرا لحسن
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
استماعكم